So anyway, uh, I watched tiger King
and it was about Theo because that guy,
if I had to pick any friend that it looks like it's, it's Theo, people are like,
Oh David spade played them in a, what do you call it?
Um, Joe Joe dirt. And I'm just like,
no Theo Von is him though. Period. Um,
and so I saw tiger King and everyone on tiger King. Uh,
I have a question for you. What the is wrong with you? You're morons everyone,
every single person on tiger King is a moron and yeah,
it's funny. And Oh yeah. Watch your show. And can you believe it?
And at arms length, you're like, wow, that's amazing that life,
but those people that are living that life they're in this world,
you could bump into him.
And that's a problem because those people are idiots,
everyone right down to it from a,
the tiger King to the other dude who wear the bandana and the hat by the way,
where one headpiece, especially if you're white,
why does everyone in the movie too? In the shows, they all like,
look like they would jerk off outside of affliction,
just staring in the front store. Storefront,
just jerking off at the new affliction designs are, Oh,
I can't wait till I come out with the affliction is the worst clothing of all
time, by the way, it's so bad. Why does it,
why do you need to have tattoos on your shirt?
Why can't you just have them on your body? Everything well affliction ever made,
it looks like it was a tattoo put on a shirt of, uh,
like my tattoos. Like,
it'll be like an Eagle on fire with the word affliction over it.
Or some dragon. God, that guy.
How about the guy who was like the big potato with the long
hair? That was just like, why do, how come everybody? Why,
why does everybody who have tigers want to as many
people around them? What is that about everyone? There is like, well,
I have I roll around with them.
big potato guy that has his beard was his goatee was white.
And he had the long hair and he, he told the documentary crew cut once.
He was like, and that's how it is cut. I think we got it that long potato guy.
He just like,
even though I was like, well, I have five girls that just follow me around.
Why do they all, why just be a cult leader? What,
what what's with the tigers? These guys are like, step one,
get tigers. Step two. all the girls.
No, except for the tiger King guy was just like
making straight dudes. him. Trying to pretend like the,
you mean married two straight dudes and them and. And they were just like,
I'm not gay. I don't know. I just, how,
how dumb do you have to be to let a guy,
if you're not gay, make you be like, ah, it.
I'll marry him and just them for a bunch of years. When the guy showed up,
when his husband,
his first husband showed up and they did the floating head of him just
interviewing him. He had no shirt on
the directors must have been like a pig and. When that happened,
if that happened to me, I would have been like, okay, let's get the guy.
And he was like, all right, where do you want to go? And I'll be like, Oh, cool.
You want to get dressed? And he'd be like, what do you mean? I'll be like,
Oh no, nevermind, no, sit down, go ahead and show it off. That's fine.
Hair all over his body. I feel kind of bad for some of these guys.
Like that guy felt kind of bad for, but just how stupid do you have to be?
To be not gay, but a guy and let him you for nine years. How dumb is that,
dude?
I mean, I'm straight.
What would have to go down for me to and let a
guy rail me for nine years?
What co what would have to go down?
I'd have to be in prison. I've said a long time ago. People are like,
Oh, how long, you know, sometimes you talk to your friends.
How long would it take for you to start guys?
What would it take if you were in PR,
what would it take for you to take me to be in prison for eight days,
eight days. That's it? That's how long a week goes by. And I'm like, all right,
I guess I gotta them. I gotta, I gotta guys with this was the deal for how long,
how long to would I have to be in jail for like,
if I was going to get out in a year,
I could probably go a year without doing it.
But if I was going to be in jail for three years, eight days, eight days,
it would take for me to guys.
And then two years later I'd get out and they'd be like, what happened?
I'd be like eight days lasted. A bunch of guys. Now let's go get these checks.
That's how it will be for me. But to just straight up, be like, okay,
I'll marry a guy because of his tigers,
even though I'm straight and let him me for nine years,
just insane.
I thought it's so weird that these guys just want to get these tigers.
And then the guy at the end with the affliction shirt and the two hats was just
like, well, I got her pregnant and we're going to get a nanny and guess what?
And showed her the picture of the nanny.
And the nanny looks like a girl that will be on Tik TOK.
And you're just like what? She's just like, and he's like,
I got to pick the nanny. He's just going to the nanny while his girl's pregnant.
And then he's like, we're going to pop this baby out of her. And then,
then we're going to get her in the gym.
Oh.
The Texas city. And our said, Hey. And I said, Hey
sir, toxic masculinity. And I don't even believe in that dumb.
Anytime a guy coughs somebody like that's toxic masculinity nowadays.
You know what, thank God for the coronavirus.
At least people aren't getting canceled anymore for for just farting.
I swear to God, dude, I'm not even gonna mention it.
But one of my buddies got outed for some.
And then the coronavirus happened and everyone forgot about that.
That dude's like, hell yeah.
He's like a bunch of tens of thousands of people died. That's fine.
But at least I get to do a deal. Now, the toxicity.
Or Sadie and or sad. Hey,
unbelievable, dude.
That made me laugh.
Do it about the tiger King when he was just like gonna get the best part about
tiger King though. And if you tell me, this is wrong, go yourself.
We don't get along the best thing in tiger King.
First of all,
the second best thing in and tiger King was when he was at the funeral.
When his, when his, when his,
one of his husbands died and he started talking about how
the dead guy would put his balls in his face whenever he needed.
And that's why he loved them and, that was the second best.
But the best part was when he was like, okay, now I headed and then.
Started singing is terrible country music. Oh,
okay. I mean, imagine your friend dies. Imagine your lover dies in your life.
Uh, man, missed him so much. I miss him so much.
He was so great. Anytime I was down, he'd put it. He'd put his balls in my face.
It's not unusual to be mad at anyone [inaudible]
Oh, okay.
Yeah, man. I just got to tell you,
we all miss him and it sucks. He was a real standup guy.
Meaning he'd stand up and put his balls over my eyes whenever I.
It's not unusual to be.
[inaudible].
God I miss my wife used to her gash at.
It. It's not unusual to be [inaudible].
Ah, man, I can't believe my wife has gone.
It's so sad. Favorite thing about it was when she used to kiss my. All.
I had it.
Holy.
Favorite thing about it was when she used to pee on me.
Not unusual to be
[inaudible] I keep forgetting. I'm not in love anymore.
Wow. I'm losing my mind. Nobody's in this room.
Dude. That's the best part of tiger King man. Oh man. Miss my husband.
He used to my boy.
Here we go. One and a two and a three. It's not unusual.
People get mad at me for milk and jokes. Go yourself. I'll do it.
I'll do this whole episode to the end. I'll do different things. Oh,
I used to love when he used to blast in my mouth.
It's not unusual.
My favorite is when he used to boot cocky me.
I keep forgetting. It's not, [inaudible].
Just, I miss my husband. He used to suck my.
[Inaudible] it kind of comes out.